um so one red pill concept is that like
being too nice doesn't always get you
results so i think a lot of guys went
through like just being so nice trying
to give a girl girl the world and then
um they realized they do that and they
get cheated on
yeah yeah so
but yeah but but it's also like the
other extreme is bad and i think that
they push the other extreme to just kind
of like
always have the upper hand always always
be in charge and and these guys are like
resenting the girls before they even get
involved with them because they think
the girls is like out to [ __ ] them over
or how to get them so i advocate
yeah being being spineless or too much
of a nice guy is obviously very very bad
and going to lead to very bad results
and being walked on and stuff
but i actually advocate that the guys
treat the girls well but also have like
a backbone
and be willing to call them out on their
[ __ ] but but don't go in with this
negative mindset that you have to like
be one up or that you have to like be
ready for them to [ __ ] you over
for for me and some of the best like you
know best guys in the game we've talked
about this
um you can treat them well there's
nothing wrong with treating a girl well
i i treat all the girls that i see very
well but when they [ __ ] up i make it
very clear that's not gonna be tolerated
and it's usually they get one strike or
a lot of times even zero strikes if it
depending on the the severity of it
but um that's like the key difference
it's like having a having a spine and
also don't be a people pleaser you know
if she says hey where did you want to go
out tonight oh it's up to you babe you
know if there's a lot of guys like that
that they don't want to actually like
have have an opinion on things or
take charge on anything or lead anything
so i think to answer
to see how i weigh in on that
they're right that it's bad to be the
nice guy and the people pleaser and the
spineless guy but they're also
advocating kind of almost the other
extreme
to
you know
where it just becomes like misogynistic
or it becomes almost like um
like like woman like they're the enemy
or something and i think that's
extremely toxic and extremely
counterproductive
because i've met tons of cool girls all
around the world
and they also
push that like lots of the hot girls are
are terrible and shitty and they're all
just like trying to [ __ ] you over even
more because they have more options and
it's not
and that's
some of the best girls i met were also
very hot you know so and i think that's
misinformation as well i don't think
those guys even have experience dating
hot girls if they did they would show it
and they never show it and you can just
talk about how they carry themselves the
hot girls wouldn't respond well to them
anyways